just four years after the blockbuster
success of big pitting and Tom knocked
it out of the park again teaming up for
a league of their own so we ate his way
through Chicago and Indiana Tom put on
30 pounds for the part of washed-up
manager Jimmy Dugan a role he originally
fought hard to get Tom wanted to part
because he had had a couple of flops now
avoids that flop it didn't do so well
and he said I want this port but be
careful what you wish for time she will
shoot it a thousand times all under the
guise of course I don't know what I want
not helping was the sweltering 100-plus
degrees shooting days in Evansville
Indiana hardwork 106° hundred-twenty on
the field a lot of people passed out
yeah a lot of puking a league of their
own was Madonna's eighth film and
Rosie's first or 16 17 nowadays penny is
the queen of the retake and know exactly
Dhoni takes a cover it from many angles
the Rockford peaches we were on set when
penny introduced the cast including her
daughter Tracy Tracy Reiner number seven
what was it like working with your mom
I've done before
brother Gary also made an appearance
working for my sister as a director was
really very exciting I took everyone
with me nepotism is in our family my
brother believes in it I believe
surprisingly Geena Davis was not Penny's
first choice to play catcher
Dottie Hinson I wanted Demi Moore to me
more I liked but by the time we came
around she was pregnant penny was
inspired to make the film after seeing a
documentary about this woman's pro
baseball league that formed in the 40s
it's about friendship it's about field
people feeling better about themselves
without a doubt one of the top 10 sports
movies of all time
[Music]